hey guys listen I want to talk about
liquids intermittent fasting and ketosis
I get a lot of questions on can I drink
this during in a minute fasting when I'm
supposed to be fasting is it gonna
interfere with my fat-burning let's talk
about that okay the first thing we're
talk about is tea can you drink tea
absolutely you can
now tea and coffee do have caffeine
obviously you can drink too much if you
drink a small amount of tea it has some
caffeine it's probably not going to be a
problem at all
but large amounts of caffeine can start
stimulating insulin but small amounts
don't seem to have an effect
okay so tea is okay of course just get
nationally decaffeinated that would be
even better
alright so coffee is coffee okay well
let's talk about coffee again I think
one in the morning would be great and I
know some people get really upset
because I you know they're used to
drinking it all day long and I say I'm
trying to take it away from them and I
don't want to do that because of the
addiction I mean the craving that they
have but the point is that too much
coffee can rev up the adrenals and
activate cortisol which can then
activate insulin okay so that's the
problem because it's a stimulant and
stimulates the adrenal now caffeine also
stimulates adrenaline which actually
does help fat burning by the way but I
wouldn't drink coffee to lose weight
alright so 1:00 in the morning I think
is gonna be fine now
as far as what to put in it is milk or
cream gonna be a problem from just
working with lots of people it's not
really a problem if you do small amounts
now let's talk about if you're adding
the bulletproof which is the butter in
there for some people they can do it
other people it's almost as if they're
taking a meal because they're consuming
a good amount of butter in there so I
mean if you want to use that as a meal I
mean go for it but if we're trying to do
in a minute fasting we're trying to fast
and not add that much fat into even the
time so you're not supposed to be eating
because anything will trigger insulin to
some degree like a meal now
sugar can we want to put sugar in there
absolutely not you can put sugar alcohol
you can put xylitol or we throat all I
don't know if I would want to put stevia
in there because it that would be kind
of a weird taste but a small amount a
coffee is okay as long as you don't add
sugar and you just do a small amount of
cream and maybe a little butter with
some people they can get away with it
other people can't so I've had mixed
reviews on that so now if you do a
coffee bean extract there are certain
final nutrients in the coffee bean that
are really beneficial for insulin
resistance and that's probably why it
helped some people lose weight but if
they don't have insulin resistance it's
not gonna happen lose weight
again that's the coffee bean extract
thing I don't want to get into that but
as far as when you roast the coffee you
kill all those phytonutrients okay
because you're heating it way up so
that's coffee try to do small amount all
right water water is not going to be a
problem you can drink water when you're
on the ketogenic diet you are gonna lose
some water so don't be afraid to drink
it I just like to add electrolytes to it
just because normally you're gonna lose
some electrolytes not just potassium but
salt to some people that all of a sudden
feel very kind of fatigued during the
ketosis diet or even intermittent
fasting we plug in a little bit of salt
and boom they just kind of perk right up
so it could be either salt or potassium
but of course don't do the tap water
juice filtered water or I like unspoiled
I like Pellegrino the best myself so
I'll drink a good amount of that per
every day or some other of spring water
bottle water I love carbon and water
myself carbonation does not interfere
with either one of these at all now
vitamin water usually comes with a lot
of sugar don't do that okay then we have
bone broth bone broth is actually a
really good thing to consume even
between your times that you're eating
and the times of your fasting because
you're getting a lot of electrolytes
with not a lot of calories okay so I
think this is totally fun to do and the
electrolytes in the nutrition
that would actually help overcome the
ketogenic flu or any symptoms that you
might have so this is okay this is okay
diet soda no because aspartame will
increase insulin so those artificial
sweeteners will increase insulin but if
you buy like a diet set of it is with
stevia or xylitol or we throat all
that's non GMO that would be fine so I'm
gonna say no for diet sodas apple cider
vinegar very okay apple cider vinegar
will help regulate blood sugars it's
great to help you if you have a fatty
liver it's great for digestion making
insulin more Unser a more sensitive so
the need for insulin goes down this is a
real good good one alcohol just keep it
below a six pack a night no I'm just
kidding
no alcohol there's certain types of
alcohol that have low calories but still
the alcohol will inhibit the liver
function and completely knock you out of
ketosis so don't consume alcohol alright
coconut water no this is a no and this
is a no because it has quite a bit of
sugar yes it has electrolytes but it has
a lot of sugar okay so I don't recommend
it again if your metabolism is really
fast you might be able to get away with
it but I'm just telling you in general
if any type of sugar or juice anything
like that will raise the insulin now
also you have unsweetened cranberry
juice and if you put it water now I used
to recommend that the problem is it
would believe it or not knock some
people out of fat-burning and I was
surprised and then I took them off that
and I have them just do the lemon and
the outside living in her vinegar and
water and it went right back in the fat
burning so that's like a test that I
found that works almond milk well almond
will a milk usually you want to get it
unsweetened and you can have some of
that it's there's not a lot of sugar in
that usually sometimes there are some
that do have
hidden sugars but as long as there's low
sugars it's gonna be okay
and I forgot to add milk well milk is
something you probably would not want to
add to this list because milk does have
a bit of sugar but again a little bit of
milk in your coffee would be okay get
the grass-fed or organic all right
thanks for watching hey thanks so much
for watching
press the subscribe button and I'm gonna
hold on one second who is this oh no one
second hey honey listen I'm right in the
middle of filming here she wants to say
hi okay I said hi I gotta go okay
but so if you like the videos press
subscribe and I will keep you updated
with the future events